before we get started the thank-yous I
just hit 100,000 subscribers thank you
all for coming on this ride with me
because you know hopefully I make it fun
and informative and that kind of fun and
informative way that sounded smarter in
my head but you know but thank you all
for subscribing to me I will keep the
videos coming for you now let's review
us some Sherlock finally
Sherlock or so I had gotten an absurd
amount of requests review Sherlock and
today I was sitting around I was bored I
had nothing to do so I was like oh I'll
watch Sherlock you know that thing that
my buddy loaned me a couple months ago
that I haven't watched and after
watching it like I said on my Twitter
I'm man enough to admit when I'm wrong I
should have watched this eons ago
Sherlock is absurdly good now this is
just a review of season 1 because I
haven't seen season two yet season 2
airs in America starting May 6th I
believe and then comes out on blu-ray
May 22nd either case I'll do a separate
video for season 2 this is all season 1
so Sherlock is a modern take on the
Sherlock Holmes story when I heard that
older oh yeah you mean they made it in
2010 it's a modern take it's like no it
takes place in the year 2010 as it was
also made in the year 2010 so you have
Sherlock Holmes and Watson in modern-day
which when you do something like that
you take something from the past you
know in the 1800s and you make it take
place now I can really blow up in your
face easily luckily Sherlock pulls it
off as good as I think it's ever gonna
go now the ones who play Sherlock Holmes
and Watson they both do a great job I
don't know much about either of them
except for the fact that Watson is Bilbo
in the new Hobbit movies and Sherlock
Holmes is supposedly the voice of Smaug
other than that they're relatively
unknown to me cuz I'm America and we
just don't know British things outside a
red dwarf and that one tea party thing
the character Sherlock Holmes he's
awesome as many of you know house from
the show house is based off of Sherlock
Holmes so you see a lot of similarities
between the two but Sherlock Holmes is
just less damaged not that I don't love
Greg house he's a cool character but
just Sherlock Holmes is a little more
likeable in fact is he's just not pissed
off at life like house is he's still
really disconnected from people like at
a point Watson was like do you realise
that there are human lives at stake in
Holmes's life does it help me solve the
case No then I don't care I just like
that I was like okay he's still
disconnected he's still all about the
game here's more about solving the case
for the sake of giving him something to
do because he gets bored really easily
because he's a really sociopathic super
genius he's just super smart I may be
taking a leap here but I believe that
Sherlock Holmes would agree that the
three stooges movie is yeah I
had to go there but I do read the
comments the show Sherlock does that
thing where you see your friends you're
like ha you were at the grocery store
how will your shoes tell me otherwise
and your friends are like you're dumb I
was at the grocery store I don't know
why you even have that conversation but
at school when a show makes you feel
cool like that and that's what the show
Sherlock
nails and does right then I felt the Guy
Ritchie movie starring Robert Downey jr.
did not one of my gripes about the Guy
Ritchie Sherlock Holmes movies is that
it doesn't actually show you what
Sherlock Holmes sees he walks into a
room he looks around he cases the place
but it doesn't tell you what his mind is
thinking in the show Sherlock he walks
into a room he assesses everything and
starts zooming in on stuff and not only
zooming in on objects but it shows old
cliff notes on the screen yeah like
writing starts coming on the screen it
shows you what his mind is processing
what he's thinking that brings you the
viewer along for the ride it helps you
ride the coattails of Sherlock Holmes is
genius at which point you have Watson
the really relatable normal character
that serves as your eyes kind of seeing
Sherlock Holmes and the situation's how
Watson sees them but when Sherlock
Holmes snaps into genius mode it shows
everything he's thinking then you can
see things through his eyes so it
appeals to your normal guy nature
through Watson and appeals to your ego
through Sherlock Holmes at that point
every part of you is completely
satisfied your ego and super-ego can
rest peacefully at night Sherlock season
1 is just three episodes long which
would be a bummer like three episodes
are you me
but each episode is an hour and a half
long so I choose to see it as three hour
and a half long movies you see it like
that you can kind of be like okay I'll
drop 27 bucks on the blu-ray no problem
perception is reality when you are a
cheap bastard
I don't consider talking about Moriarty
a spoiler because you know he's gonna be
in the Sherlock shouts like any good
Ninja Turtles movie will have shredder
but if I'm gonna be completely honest
when I saw Moriarty I knew I was going
to do this I know I was gonna compare
him to the Jared Harris Moriarty you
know the Moriarty and the Guy Ritchie
Sherlock Holmes movies if I'm an honest
so far I prefer the Jared Harris
Moriarty you know that quiet persona of
someone who has complete control of the
situation just by being in the room
scares the living out of you
because you know when he's just looking
at you he's processing everything I got
that from the Jared Harris Moriarty I
did not get that from this Moriarty I
don't know how we can be in seeing them
- that's the thing about season 1 and
season 2 when they're done with season 1
they get feedback from fans and they
could just tweak Moriarty however so
we'll see how he is in season 2 but so
far I prefer Jared Harris but Sherlock
Holmes the character and the story as a
whole the BBC Sherlock for sure BBC
Sherlock is everything I wanted in a
Sherlock Holmes story is what I wanted
in the movies really super-smart
dialogue super-smart characters
relatable characters it's funny when it
wants to be you know you laugh at stuff
Sherlock Holmes is a super character
super badass he's what everyone wants to
be kind of funny that when you're a kid
you want to be like super me
you know just physically invincible as
you get older you're like no I just want
to be a super genius like Sherlock
Holmes they played on the strengths of
the Sherlock Holmes character and story
and they did it to the fullest best
Sherlock Holmes rendition I've seen I
recommend the show to everyone to
everyone who recommended the show to me
thank you you all kick ass and you're
just smart people so your favorite super
genius Sherlock Holmes ish characters
doesn't even have to be a good guy can
be a bad guy if you say dr. robotnik
that's cool
whoever your favorite super genius is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more